we have seen some of these rescues that
have been going on throughout this area
are simply amazing emergency crews have
brought thousands of people to safety
and volunteers from all over are helping
with boats and high water vehicles david
begno is in bel air that's a hard hit
area just southwest here of houston
david good morning
norah good morning here in bel air you
see the high water truck behind me
they're using that right now to go into
flooded areas where you can only have
that kind of truck or a boat they also
have firefighters with boats right in
front of the firehouse that they are
about to deploy the power has gone out
in this section of bel air and this
morning the houston police department is
putting out another call if you've got a
boat and you've got time come and help
us people have been coming from all over
the good folks of south louisiana
mobilized the cajun navy it's just good
people with a good heart trying to do
the right thing and they have been
coming since yesterday anybody with a
boat who wanted to help showed up here
and they had been working throughout the
night
okay we'll try to get a boat out here
around the clock search and rescue teams
have been working to take stranded
victims to safety more than 50 000 911
calls have come in overwhelming first
responders the coast guard has only
responded to a fraction of those
requests on sunday local officials
pleaded for help i ask for volunteers to
come forward with boats and high water
vehicles
there are a lot of people of course who
just did it on their own enter jeff
chase if everyone did this we'd have a
lot less to worry about chase and his
friend brian brees helped a family of
four evacuate their flooded home sunday
night the family had been calling 9-1-1
since 6
yourself in harm's way to
help others is
awesome
chase is just one of hundreds of people
who showed up wanting to help when this
big rig drifted into danger civilian
samaritans grabbed some rope and pulled
the driver to safety spirit of texas
that's what it's all about
we found denise lucille holding her
six-month-old son wading through waist
high water you have a place to go yeah
to my in-laws house right here on belair
and fishing watch watch the water watch
the water man watch the lift and lift
the baby
sue madison has four feet of water in
her home when we found her she was just
looking for a place to sleep the house
is totaled all my furniture is totaled
but what's the smile
it could be worse you're here
right
good luck
such great perspective in a disaster
zone it won't stop the rain just will
not let up if you're in your home and
you have power and you're watching this
right now or if you're talking to
somebody who's in their home
let them know that the coast guard is
specifically saying if the only way to
get you out is on your rooftop you are
asked to put something on the roof that
will attract the attention of the pilots
as as they fly over nora it is virtually
impossible this morning to know how many
people are still in their home we have
heard from folks who've said i called
and i was basically told you're on the
list we will get to you as soon as we
can
i know david and with these mandatory
evacuations this morning i think there's
going to be more of that david thank you
so much